não existem muros e grades estão altos
capazes de isolar as pessoas não existem
muros e grades estão altos capaz de
separar a sociedade livre da sociedade
confinada em presídios e penitenciárias
por mais que vocês que a sociedade se
sinta segura a cada prisão realizada
pela polícia por mais que cada sentença
condenatória o juiz assine
a sociedade também sinta mais segurança
o que ocorre exatamente o contrário
exatamente o contrário quanto mais temos
encarcerado mais altos são os índices de
criminalidade
eu há 30 anos trabalha no sistema
penitenciário
nunca estive preso um dos meus maiores
elogios que recebi até hoje a trabalhar
isso com pesquisa jornalisticamente foi
do governador do estado foi chamado uma
entrevista coletiva para jornalistas ali
e eu sentado quase ao lado dele é descer
da mesa e era alguns governadores o
secretário de justiça falando sobre o
sistema penitenciário e o secretário
apresentava dados e eu contestava o
secretário apresentava dados e
contestava o secretário tentava dados
aconteceu na quinta contestação
contestação governador num 1 segurou pra
mim assim escuta feliz com o irmãozinho
sabe tudo de presídio e experiência
própria
foi uma brincadeira mas que eu levei
como o elogio é um tema difícil mas pra
falar sobre essa questão sistema
penitenciário como um todo
eu não vejo um exemplo melhor do que o
presídio central de porto alegre já foi
considerado o pior presídio do brasil
por uma cpi do congresso
ele também é seguidamente alvo de de
denúncias à organização dos estados
americanos por violação dos direitos
humanos e é o maior
a presença do brasil porque nenhum outro
presídio é presídio destinado a presos
provisórios abriga cinco quase 5.000
presidente é presidiários como o central
presos provisórios são aqueles que estão
lá por si sem sentença condenatória
ainda estão na prisão preventiva
decretada ou por ter sido pegos em
flagrantes e esses quase 5 mil presos
eles dividem um espaço onde caberia no
máximo 1900 na média da 2,5 presos por
vaga
uma situação dessa natural que ocorram
problemas no presídio a começar pelos
estruturais é tem uma galeria lá em cima
da galeria com 400 presos e três
banheiros três banheiros para 400 presos
então além do auto controle biológico
inclusive que essas empresas têm t
eles têm que enfrentar problemas
estruturais como o entupimento de
esgotos
é muita gente para usar pouco pouco
banheiro e então o entupimento dos canos
e de tudo de todos os banheiros além dos
13 mas nas outras galerias também a
mesma coisa
e pra mim e pra amenizar esse problema
dos presos tiraram os cantos externos do
esgoto
com isso cada vez que um puxe uma
descarga lá em cima
escolhe uma cachoeira no pátio que eles
mesmo culpa e também seus familiares em
dia de visita
lógico que isso também causa outros
problemas inclusive problemas de saúde
mas essa superlotação também provoca
efeitos é na estrutura interna e para
que cada uma das celas com capacidade
para oito presos não tivesse que
abrigará cerca de 30 a 40
a solução encontrada pelo próprio estado
foi retirar portas das celas
então por quê
prepara que os presos pudessem então
ocupar também os corredores das galerias
então a gente não tem preso continue
cela temos preso continue galé em
galerias inclusive os corredores viram
dormitórios na galeria com 400 presos
circulando livremente pelos corredores
com isso o estado ali no planeta
nem a guarda entra numa galeria dessas
quando os presos estão presentes medo de
confusão medo de represália e onde o
estado não entra ainda mais dentro do
presídio o crime tomar conta e
obviamente o estado não está ali para
controlar o cumprimento de pena de cada
um desses presos
o crime tomar conta e de que forma o
crime tomar conta através de facções
criminosas através de organizações
criminosas
no presente ano
porto alegre a divisão se dá das
galerias por facções e isso aí é é
acontece em todos os grandes presídios
brasileiros são separados facções não
são separados por tipo de crime cometido
por por é recebeu entre residentes e
primários não são separados por facções
um aval do estado com aval não com a
ajuda do estado e como estado ali não
penetra e não tem como falar com 400
presos mesmo tempo cada galeria e elege
seu líder
plantão de galeria na palavra do na
palavra do estado o prefeito na palavra
e na li no linguajar dos presos e
obviamente uma galeria dominada por uma
facção e se lida vai ser o líder da
facção
isso é uma obviedade se não for ele vai
ser um laranja indicado por ele mas o
estado não só ele não é só omisso nessa
história toda ele e contribui com o
crescimento das facções porque quando um
preso quando alguém é preso na rua e
levado para o presídio
a primeira pergunta que lhe é feita lá é
pertença a alguma facção se ele pertence
a uma facção se é um bala na cara se é
humano
ele vai ser encaminhado para a galeria
correspondente ou seja o estado está
ajudando a organizar mais um de vocês
aqui ó
e se ele não for um preso um jovem que
foi pego furtando um carro quer o tipo
de delito não tem ligação com nenhum
como nenhuma facção igualmente ele vai
ter que pôr uma galeria de facção aí
pode ser aleatoriamente
aí pode ser colocado aleatoriamente uma
galeria 10 chegando lá ele vai ser gasto
sem nada que o estado não dá com o chão
está não dá não dá e tegene estado não
dá papel higiênico está não dá nada vai
chegar sem nada mas o usuário vai ser
bem recebido
filha da facção vai receber olha aqui
bem pode vir tranqüilo pode vir
tranqüilo que a gente apóia a gente é
tudo sobretudo do irmão tudo irmão a
gente apoia e vai chegar vai ser bem
recebido vai receber um colchão de
repente ou de repente foi ter que
dividir um colchão com o outro vai
receber um sabonete ó ó mãe vai receber
papel higiênico recebeu os itens
necessários para a sobrevivência dele
dentro
só que tudo tem preço né
óbvio que a facção não é boazinha esse
ponto diz não é uma entidade
filantrópica acção é do crime
na primeira visita que ele receber o
líder da facção mais e melhor falando
está colaborando e tal mas também
precisa colaborar para a facção até
ajudar outros e tal aí vamos pedir otter
familiar trazer uma grana pra dentro mas
não tem dinheiro bom tão facilmente e
também ela bota uma droga para dentro a
colaboração de um jeito terão colaborado
com a droga até lá pra dentro de certa
bom digamos que esse preço não recebe
familiar ou família não tem como levar
mesmo e 77 da facção não vai abandonar
ele chegou a quito não tudo bem vai
ficando mais quando a gente vai te
ajudando e todos nós sabemos
no brasil não tem pena perpétua um dia
ele preso vai sair de lá
aí então vai pagar a conta que do lado
de fora e como é que ele vai pagar a
conta
lá dentro tem muitos celulares lá dentro
olha o sinal é maravilhoso pega melhor
que muitos lugares o sinal do central
olha já experimentei gente pega que é
uma maravilha melhor que muitos lugares
é o líder vai ligar pra ele e vai dizer
o fulano
agora o seguinte então agora chegou a
hora de pagar a conta
é roubar precisamos de dois carros
semana
e aí que eu digo a questão da separação
da sociedade livre da confinada
aí nós estamos aqui na rita dos reis eu
sei que tive problemas seríssimos tempo
e de roubo de carros aos estudantes
aí qualquer um de nós parados numa
esquina chega alguém e osmar na cabeça
entrega o carro perdeu perdeu o trem ou
carro
muitas vezes a gente não percebe
assassinatos às vezes e e assassinatos
ou um sonho criminosos é não é e também
não essa bala perdida
está havendo vários inocentes e c mortos
nessa guerra do tráfico em nada tem a
ver com ela
assalto a banco assaltos a empresas alta
residência
é que eu digo assim muitas vezes não se
percebe mas a sociedade livre paga a
conta alta pelo que pelo descaso do
estado dentro dos presídios
estamos aqui achando que quanto mais
presos mas menos gente para cometer
crimes aqui fora mas faz tempo ele faz
tempo que aconteçam os presídios deixou
de impedir que alguém cometesse um crime
mas não cometer diretamente mas ele tem
vários soldados na rua para cometer
muita gente pra cometer fora facções são
numerosas dentro e fora dos presídios
porque elas são cada vez crescendo mais
e com esse apoio do estado que lidar
membros novos e que permite que é que
elas dominem o interior dos presídios
aliás o crime se mostra muito mais
organizado do que o próprio estado em
vários aspectos
bom não estou aqui pregando no som num
ovo pra pegar o lucho nizzo dizer que
não tem que prender obviamente que não é
nada disso no entanto não tem que
aprender a prisão é um mal necessário
em sociedades em perfeitas como a nossa
questiono o tipo de encarceramento que é
feito aqui no brasil
primeiro porque é quando se estuda
direito eu por ser parte do curso de
direito mas o suficiente para aprender
uma das lições que eu tive é que o
direito penal é a última instância do
direito à pena de prisão é a última
instância do direito penal quando todos
os outros falharem se recorre a ele
há várias outras formas de conciliação
dentro do direito
antes de chegar no direito penal mas
quando isso é impossível tudo em seu
recorde e não é a mesma coisa deveria
valer em relação ao encarceramento
seu último recurso deveremos recorrer a
penas alternativas a serviços prestados
à comunidade e até de uma forma com aqui
o infrator parte de alguma forma pelo
mal causado à sociedade é realmente
estaria pagando não faria só só a cdu
punido materializa tudo pagã claro isso
aí nos crimes mais leves não para os
crimes mais pesado evidentemente
assaltante à mão armada é evidentemente
que tá botando a sociedade resulta botou
a arma na minha cabeça de alguém um dia
ele matou ele comete um latrocínio mas o
que se vê no brasil hoje e talvez por
isso também é o brasil hoje tem mais uma
das maiores população carcerária do
mundo o que se vê é o encarceramento em
massa principalmente com a lei dos
tóxicos das drogas de 2006
além das drogas está fazendo com que os
presídios ficam lotados de jovens
principalmente jovens entre 18 e 25 anos
de periferia ea maioria negros
aliás esse é o perfil que a sociedade
tem do traficante
vamos imaginar um traficante que se
imagina um favelado negro favelado jovem
unidade conhecia a história de algum
desses negros favelados jovens ou mesmo
que não seja negros ou mais favelados
jovens a maioria deles quase a
totalidade são analfabetos funcionais
mora em comunidade já discriminadas não
tem perspectiva de vida
e essas comunidades onde eles moram são
dominadas por que para grandes
traficantes vendem entre aspas mas são
traficantes poderosos que ando com arma
na cintura que nesta sociedade machista
conquistou 11 as menininhas dalida da
região andando com carro bomba os capos
correntes de ouro e servem de exemplo
para os jovens
esse jovem semi analfabeta é um exemplo
que esse jovem tem é a perspectiva deles
e muitos deles sabe que vamos renovar e
mas desenvolver intensamente enquanto e
enquanto eu puder ea maneira que eles em
que eles enxergam e até porque o real
não sejamos sinceros nós mesmos
terminamos a gente vê um jovem mal
investido aqui a gente já fica assim
pensamos é que vai ressaltar aqui no
hype nós mesmos ajudamos a isolar certa
fora a não dar visibilidade para esse
jovem ea visibilidade que ele encontra
da maneira que ele encontrou de fazer
com que a gente enxerga e cantando com
uma arma onde o vendendo drogas para a
classe média e se sente importante ele
se sente alguém e isso é trabalho e numa
sociedade que nem a nossa
sociedade neoliberal em que há uma
grande diferença é uma péssima
distribuição de renda
o estado costuma compensar sua ausência
porquanto estado econômica do estado
social reforçando estado penal
não se investe tanto em educação das
periferias principalmente mas investe
mais policiamento em policiamento vai
ser mais os presídios e os preciso que o
rio que o estado pouco inverso
lógico que nós temos exemplos positivos
de de presídios eu acho que isso é é
salutar temos que colocar é que temos
alguns exemplos positivos raros mas
temos que são os como aqui em canoas em
canoas a gente tem um presídio em um
presídio pode ser considerado hoje um
modelo por enquanto enquanto não
estragarem que é onde os presos de cada
preso que lá entra recebe um kit
esse kit é da uniformes hoje os itens
que necessita para a higiene pessoal e
também só que esses presos lá de canoas
lá eles trabalham lá eles estudam coisas
que nos outros presídios é muito raro
como central
só que esses preso custa ao estado 2500k
por mês sem contar o valor pago aos
funcionários no presídio central
o custo é mais ou menos mil reais
vocês vão dizer bom mas é muito caro
2.500 por mês cada preso
só que o índice de reincidência em
canoas
ele varia entre 9 e 18 por cento no
central o índice de residências
reincidência é 70% de cada dez presos
que saem de lá sete retorno e muitas
vezes pelo cometimento de crimes piores
daquele primeiro porque porque está na
mão das facções
eu costumo abordar esse tema difícil nas
redes sociais a segunda crítica assim
muitas vezes as pessoas me dizem assim
está com pena que acho que estou
defendendo que está com pena adota leva
pra casa só que se eu fosse adotar todos
que já vem recomendar entre uma
população em casa maya que presido
central certamente mas digo a vocês que
conclamo a pensar esse tema é importante
pois não existem muros e grades estão
aos capaz de separar a sociedade livre
da sociedade convidada
[Aplausos]